i'm spooky here we go
what's his name
i don't i don't know what we're doing
okay go go back
what was that welcome
it's me and
me
we're not on face cam because we're
playing spoopy game in the dark you
wouldn't be able to see us anyway we're
gonna play a really scary game are you
ready are you scared yeah
i'm ready i'm not you're really scared
no no i'm not scared you're super
scared got three new cadavers and no one
else can make it in right now okay we're
gonna i get it we're gonna be more damn
there's some more paint huh look at us
look at this
so how should we do this should you
control the mouse and i control the
keyboard sure okay here we go all right
i'll be keyboard you'll be mine yeah
where are my keys the keys are right
there
yeah let's get them
yeah
keys to the apartment car and front door
that's convenient i want keys like that
hey look at us check us out do i just
eat yeah you just ain't i'm okay you
want to do dishes hey look
yeah come on check bamba
what take bubba
yeah
no bubba
all right
okay here we go here
hey we're good at this
what
okay
i think this is one one guy who made
this game and we're playing the demo
oh oh
no no
okay i didn't break we're good it's
raining inside now oh god did we just
glitch the game i think we released the
game
oh no what did you do
oh
wait go out
go out
oh yeah maybe go in and out again that's
smart sometimes sometimes you just feel
like rain follows you everywhere i think
you can oh you can oh nice so much nicer
look at us
yeah let's grab a g-fuel cup and put it
down and grab a vase for no all right
this is put down that all right
no
i don't have my clipboard
is it me
i think you open the thing
then i should be able to do this
i don't know what i'm doing what is that
what it's me oh
don't do that turn them back on
okay okay
okay
how nice
okay oh check this out
that's creepy bubba check let me check
the desk let's stick the drawers
oh my god she said it we're in the
embalming room involving a room no wait
a moment
we got it
yeah
you oh that was actually good there you
go you asked oh
okay and i'm gonna all right not bad you
know what i was wrong you were right i
can't i can't use i can't use it why not
i can't use that we're in a fuse
thing
look at another one
i can't use that all right you know what
you know what
how much toilet paper do you need
embalming
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's creepy come on what do you mean
it's a dead body and we're alone that's
creepy
it's all right for now
that's the creepiest oh yeah we should
close this door yeah yeah now i like it
better you like it
[Music]
enter cadaver information
okay
is he dead
it looks comfy
oh
did you hear that did you hear that did
you hear that what was that
who made noise
did you make noise
is that a pizza oven
wow
they're offended it's in italian is that
what's happening
oh
we're gonna have to pizza on the guy
[Music]
oh you know what's in those
oh pizzas
go closer
we got margarita
you got scared
the noise of the door
it's like when i randomly yell in videos
and people are like jesus
what do you mean
look at him what is that what leave
gurney
whoa
gurney you're coming with us gurney
oh
to return a body to his cold storage
open the bay with the body's name okay
what's making that noise i don't know i
don't like that noise
oh i don't like going backwards yeah
okay okay let's leave him here and let's
look
who's his name then it's gotta be
frederick yeah there's no one else
there's no one else
it's frederick
all right frederick you're going in my
dude we're scooching you over gurney
is this name gurney or no
or maybe
you gotta pull left while i go okay pull
yeah that's it
these two something's gonna happen i i
don't have my clipboard
maybe you can just chill outside for now
i feel like the game told us what to do
and we clearly didn't listen
maybe we need to maybe we have to
prepare him and he's not ready yet maybe
we have to use some of the fluids and
stuff
no okay let's try that yeah
oops
you saw that well just because you said
but oh
well wasn't it i don't know all right
that was spooky
what's his name
uh i don't know what we're doing
okay go go
what was that
what did you do
what did you do you scared me
you jumped this game sudden
you get to see random noises computer
line i don't have my clipboard okay we
don't care that you don't have the oh
gurney uh oh we gotta get our clipboard
it's almost like the game i've been
telling us to get our clipboard where's
our clip is that our clipboard is that a
clipboard no
uh
[Music]
okay we just need our clipboard now
where's our damn clipboard
i can't hold anything else okay we're
kind of full on stuff
how this sounds uh let's go back maybe
that's a clipboard
holy crap at least i can keep track of
things blank see egg it wise isn't
swedish
black stick
okay retrieve body from concert return
body to cold search okay okay okay stop
stop
pull out the rack by holding the use
button and walking backwards
there we go
we're so smart
wheel the gurney over it and the body
will automatically
get out of here
shoo closer closer closer i want to see
her no you weirdo no why not
i'm gonna die i don't wanna die put the
guy in it's fine it's fine don't worry
about it that's so crazy you gotta make
eye contact i would rather if this is
happening in real life no no
we're not looking i mean no
no you know that she's gonna come the
second we turn around
[Music]
oh it worked
oh
yeah we see you
there she goes
where did she go
ah that's so cool
okay so now you gotta hold on your left
click to hold it down
all right
done good job well done let's get paying
we're done all right
let's put this back the guri we're done
right
return brought it to close search excuse
me i believe we just did that can you
see but wait what are we supposed to do
yeah maybe we have to register it on the
computer ah
okay let's charge her are you right are
you scared to charge or should we do it
oh wait with this
with that we should charge her with that
okay i mean we definitely scared her
away uh she's scared she's scared
chicken
[Music]
that is weird
it's not supposed to do that
that is not supposed to you're weird uh
okay
all
that's creepy stop it
okay it's a little wonky but it it's
kind of spoopy
[Music]
all right have we done the thing what do
you mean we did it let's go to the
computer put down something
are we done
maybe
okay we figured it out by brain power
we're gonna bring this back and we gotta
skedaddle again
that was good keep doing that yeah
i'm gonna bring her oh wait we gotta
pull her out first i think
okay girl
okay are you drunk oh nice look at us
all right
are we no
cool
oh oh look
oh my god stop
bro we're not scared okay hello hello
what's up let's check you out how did
she does not care she just does not care
all right we gotta check her out enter
markings in the computer and print
report okay
okay so
right foot
it's got a bingo left arm
that was good you got it well done
uh i think we need to record the marks
maybe click oh yeah use the clipboard
clipboard
there you go i think we just made a note
oh we just wrote it down
okay got it all
right okay go back
go around is there anything else i feel
like her face right oh
uh huh
protein
ah
oh
these are oh she got scratches on her
yeah
and the other thing must be her face
that's it
where was it there yeah job done
we got it let's get paid
oh oh okay
yeah
there we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
right shoulder oh
that's right shoulder
contestion
yo
oh my god i did so much i need to file
the copy up front
what was that
oh
hey
hello
[Music]
bye
hello you want to come in brainy
this game is a whack-ass
i can't hold anything else
[Music]
that's weird
it's rigor more it is it's fine
oh she's telling you where to go
did he get longer oh i think he did
girl
we thought
it's fine we got this yeah of course
oh no
why will we follow when she's pointing
like that out was it this farthest part
of it yeah it's always been like this
don't worry about it okay
oh it's gonna be oh
[Music]
so the clip or hey would you mind
helping me i need to fill out the
clipboard
whoa that was freaky what the hell oh
god
oh
all right we get it you're dead whatever
excuse me
we haven't seen her for so long
uh all right so we got infused i can't i
can't use that here i love how chill
she's about it
we just had to interact with her somehow
oh my god are you serious
well we made it oh my god
we were supposed to get the paper right
[Music]
i can't hold anything
so it is that girl right yeah yeah she
did she didn't help wait so where do we
leave it that's a great question this
game is too intuitive yeah maybe
somewhere here i would just leave it
right there oh in the paper box
no
oh my god we're so dumb
it's time to embalm
that's not it that's not it
that's not it that's not it that's not
it
okay stop
i don't know
oh
no
oh no you have to grab it oh oh do you
see in the window let's see what
little lady this is chilling he's gonna
get a can you grab it or not i can't
oh my god it says here mix involving
fluid in pump methanol
okay do you remember where the meth is
oh spooky
maybe she can help us we clearly need
someone hey
you know
[Music]
where did she go come on we did all of
these and you're oh i'm grateful
ungrateful smokeball oh hey
get outta open the window lady excuse me
lady fine hey
what do i do
you're so fearless you're like whatever
all right here we go
um
let me see
can you
no no no no no why would you do that did
i reset the game
oh my god
what i didn't mean to
anyway if you want marzia back smash
like subscribe i have fun that's a
really bad game i'm sorry you need to
work i enjoyed it though it was too
glitchy well
it made it fun and
i like the setting
so yeah fair enough all right well
thanks for joining
uh a little late halloween special but
there it is and brofist
what a miserable breakfast there it is
thank you